Theresa is in Missouri hey Teresa how
are you hi Dave are ya
better than I deserve what's up hi okay
well here's a quick synopsis so our
family has moved five times in the past
four years due to my husband's job he
does contract work and for the past a
little over a year now we've been living
in Missouri because his company at the
time was helping out a local company and
they offered him the local company
offered him a long-term job so he
decided to take it because we were tired
of traveling around but in taking that
he took a significant cut in his income
and now as let's see last week the
company that he was originally working
for has now told him that there's
they've offered him a job again where he
if we if it takes it we would be in the
same area for three years and our income
would basically I think I figured it out
it would be like a six and seven percent
increase in our income a six sixty seven
sixty seven right now
he makes approximately 54 after taxes
and everything like that and it would go
up to around ninety four and I guarantee
you bean and I guarantee you been a poet
for three years and it would be staying
put for three years and on so we're
basically trying to and during the let
me just start during the trying that we
have been here we bought a house and as
of this past week we actually refinance
it to get a lower tax rate and we're
actually waiting on the results from the
assessor right now so we're just going
to try and decide if it's worth moving
again or if it's a grass is green on
there
side of the fence thing because we do
have debt and we want to pay that off
and stuff like that and it would mean
obviously operating our family again and
just very hard to figure out what to do
well not only operating them again but
then again in three years right the only
thing about the three years thing we
thought about well maybe going there and
doing that and gaining complete
financial freedom paying off our debt
paying off the house completely and then
coming back here like we would rent out
the house what we were gone no we can
probably rent the house no okay you
don't rent a house out and then come
back to it you will you will be sadly
disappointed with that experience okay
because renters will not take care of
your house like you do that's not gonna
be a thing you're going to enjoy
especially long-distance landlording and
too much risk and you got other debts no
you don't need to get in that business
if you leave you need to sell your house
and decide where you want to be so if
you sell this house and you move and you
stay there for three years mm-hmm
there's nothing that says you have to
come back to where you are now where
would you want no there's not
where would you want to go somewhere
warm Texas Florida where is the new
place for three years it is in the most
opposite of all opposites iOS okay
winters are there boo you said um he he
does he's like a cable tech so he does
contract work they were on fiber-optic
cable oh okay so he goes where the work
is yes exactly and it's a really good
job for a single guy but not so much for
someone with a family yeah yeah okay the
only way I know to make these decisions
that make sense is you need to pan back
and say not three years from now not
three days from now but 10 or 20 years
from now
which of these decisions takes us to our
goal where does he want to be and you
want to be in 20 years do what do you
want to be doing then what's he doing
for a career and how is he gonna get
stabilized because one of the things we
know 20 years from now based on this
discussion is you want to be stabilized
during you know 20 years and today you
want to have been stabilized for a long
time right and so which of those two
choices get you there in other words
let's say you go out there to Iowa for
three years and you get completely
debt-free and you use all this money
that he's making as your one last run
then what's he gonna do well that kind
of falls back on me because I have a
master's degree in counseling and I've
actually been itching to go back to that
one what I asked you I asked what he was
gonna do OH
actually was gonna say he was probably
going to be stay home at dad and I would
work yeah okay you know why that is is
just because he didn't have a plan
that's the only reason you did that and
so I'm not gonna force you know you
don't have a plan
he's been you guys been running around
chasing money in 14 different cities
four five cities in four years now you
finally got it lit you thought you had a
plan and now someone offered to almost
double your income and I had disrupted
your plan you don't have a plan no
reason you can't go ahead and engage
your counseling degree right where
you're sitting you don't have to leave
town to do that and he can stay right
where he's sitting and not take the for
the pay increase or you can go take the
pay increase but it needs to be along
the path where he has his next career
choice picked out and you have your next
career choice picked out but him sitting
on his hands because he doesn't have a
plan is not a plan and that's exactly
how you got here it's not because his
great desire is to be home with the kids
that's BS I can tell by talking to you
that's what's going on and so you guys
need to develop a plan
that's a longer term you've been living
short-term thinking and you need some
long-term thinking and that will give
you the solutions and tell you which of
these decisions is the wise decision pan
back back up from it get a better view
of all the trees you're too far into the
forest and start making a decision that
takes your word both of you want to be
and you're living your best possible
life twenty years from now which of
these decisions takes you there my first
opinion is it's not moving or if it is
it's moving for a permanent job not the
one he was offered and that job is
taking him into a career that is his
long-term career that's my guess cuz I'm
thinking he'd never really wanted to do
this job in the first place he's just
doing it for money just to feed his
family there's nothing wrong with that
but it's not a good long-term plan
that's the only thing wrong with it so
that's what I would tell you to do
thanks for the call all right there's
two couple principals there all of us
can use in making our decisions we I did
I read a study 25 years ago when I first
started doing the show almost thirty
years ago that said that people who are
wealthy when making a purchase decision
or an investment decision or for that
matter a career decision ask themselves
how's this gonna turn out 20 years from
now 30 years from now 50 years from now
people who are not wealthy when making a
purchase decision or a career decision
has themselves how's this gonna feel
Friday they're planning window is about
six days thank God it's Friday oh god
it's Monday but if you're planning if
you can extend your planning window as
an act of your intellect as an act of
your will you have a greater tendency to
become successful in most any area of
your life but certainly in the area of
money and career and so when you're
asking yourself what fit you know is it
is this gonna take me where I want to be
20 years from now does this purchase do
that does this decision do that does
this experience do that does this
investment do that does this career do
that not not how does it feel today
children
what feels good adults devise a plan and
follow it and that's the principle so
ask yourself when you get ready to buy
this car is this a good long-term
decision I'm getting ready to buy this
house is this a good long-term decision
I'm getting ready to study this field of
study it's just a good long-term
decision I'm getting ready to take this
job this is a good long-term decision
this is how wealthy people think if you
want to be wealthy people are you got to
start thinking like them and it'll lead
you in that direction